I'm gonna try not to splash oh you
passed the course that's very good you
did you cut fastest it probably should
so how you gonna set it well like
everybody so what you're supposed to do
is it's a very gentle back and forward
motion and there's no saint
what yeah you don't think any same cuz
if you do all drop him you're gonna end
up you're keepin everywhere and your
oxalate I know this into the room that
you're here so it's a bit quiet
sophisticated thing she doesn't it
I've never felt so nervous drinking a
cup of tea
okay interest there's slurping mmm don't
give me this really noise was that kind
of up is a Peter worried should I have
in sitio oh no the only thing I could
see you know how when you watch a dog
can I go to the water ball yes it was a
bit of kind of you know you may think
you know you were gonna say I only tell
me as you did start licking the tea and
so obvious what you do just a benvenuti
up and delicious that's why the way you
drag that T is the reason afternoon tea
takes three hours I possibly yes